how were you able to show you guests say
keep it crispy so go down the line hey
man keep it crispy that's right that's
it haha can I get it back if if I hear
they're I got you do yours sorry you
just saying okay didn't email recipe man
yeah I'll go I'll go I'll go announcer
again okay keep it crispy you do a great
Oprah when you do his Oprah
that man have another shot yeah wait how
are you Richard Brock you know I think
we know any how to do it I mean you get
every boss Ryan crispy
so fans of the podcast notice at the end
of every show I always ask my guests if
they would mind saying keep it crispy
and it would be a total mass of thrill
for the first time ever to have this TV
studio audience say keep a crispy do you
guys think we could do that okay so
let's do it all together on 3 123 Matt
Braunger Thomas Middleditch connect
everybody keep it going